this is a true story my mom asks me  february of my senior year of high  school so what are we doing about  college i laugh i go what do you mean  it's over i'm gonna go right into the  business she rolls up on me stares me  down and scares the [ __ ] out of me and  goes you're going to college figure it  out and don't make it a community  college and my mom's an angel by the way  a week later i get a postcard in the  mail from mount ida college in newton  massachusetts i fill out the postcard  with my name and address nothing else  send it back in three weeks later my  guidance counselor miss balangee if  you're out there big shout out i've  never met her guy in my four years of  high school looks me dead in the face  and drops the most iconic line ever nice  to meet you let me get this straight  you're going to college and i go to  mount ida college